I am sitting and sweating and so I  thought logically this should go on  camera to be shared with the internet  because this is an event in my life that  is absolutely necessary to be shared  with everyone that I've never met before  but exists through social media  platforms like YouTube etc trailer maybe  - and also sometimes somewhere also let  sweat sweat sweat you sweat sweat sweat  doing my laundry right now that's  excited like who's excited I'm excited  on your side this should be something  that a shared this is a video that  should be shared this should be shared  this should be shared that should be  shared  I got a gchat by